اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى من الجليل
الاعلى على الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه
بايجاز اهلا بكم اسبوع من القصف المتواصل
على قطاع غزه ارتفاع عدد الشهداء الى اكثر
من 2200 ووزاره الصحه في غزه تقول ان
الاحتلال ارتكب مجزره في دير البلح خلفت
عشرات الشهداء والجرحى والمتحدث باسم
اليونيسيف يقول للجزيره ان اكثر من 700
طفل في غزه فقدوا حياتهم منذ بدء القصف في
حين حذرت الاونروا من قرب نفاد المياه في
القطاع كتائب القسام تعلن قصف تلبيب
وعسقلان وكبوت س نريم وعبور السياج الفاصل
شرق خان يونس والاشتباك مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي وتدمير عدد من الياته والجيش
الاسرائيلي يقر باسقاط مروحيه بصاروخ
اطلقه القسام خلال عمليه السبت
الماضي مسؤول امريكي يعلن التوصل لاتفاق
يسمح للاجانب بمغادره غزه من معبر رفح
والجزيره تحصل على صور تظهر مشاهد الدمار
الذي طال الجانب الفلسطيني من معبر رفح
جراء القصف الاسرائيلي ووضع جدران اسمنتيه
امام البوابه المصريه في
المعبر طهران تحذر من اتساع التوتر وتقول
ان الحلول السياسيه لا تزال ممكنه خلال
ساعات فقط بلينكن يشدد من الرياض على
اهميه العمل لتفادي توسع الصراع ووزير
الخارجيه السعودي يدعو الى تسهيل دخول
المساعدات الى غزه والخارجيه القطريه تندد
بما سمته تهجي قسريا للفلسطينيين في
القطاع الى
اللقاء
ه